THERE IS NO SECRET THAT I LOVE
AMERICA, THAT IS WHY NO ONE
ASKED ME TO THE SAIDEE HAWKINS
DANCE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY KNEW I ALREADY HAD A DATE.
BUT LATELY AMERICA HAS BEEN
CHANGING.
SHE IS NOT THE 1950S BEAUTY THAT
I USED TO LOVE BACK WHEN I WAS
WAITING TO BE BORN.
NO.
TO BE HONEST, SOMETIMES I DON'T
EVEN RECOGNIZE MY COUNTRY ANY
MORE.
MY FIRST FADING MEMORY IS
FOOTBALL.
YESTERDAY WAS THE SUPER BOWL
WHICH WAS RUINED WHEN THIS POP
LOCKING MOUNTAIN RANGE JUSTIN
TIMBERLAKE DID A HALFTIME SHOW.
THIS ELITIST CUCK SHOULDN'T BE A
THREUD DO IS AM MICHAEL JACKSON
COSPLAY AROUND A FOOTBALL FIELD
AFTER WHAT HE SAID TO REPORTERS
LAST WEEK WHEN THEY ASKED HIM IF
HIS SON MIGHT PLAY FOOTBALL ONE
DAY.
>> HE WILL NEVER PLAY FOOTBALL,
NO.
>> TO SAY MY KID CAN'T PLAY
FOOTBALL BECAUSE I'M WORRIED HE
MIGHT TAKE A HIT IT IS
INDICATIVE OF THE SOFTNESS WE
GET.
TO ME IT IS AN EYE ROLL, HERE WE
GO AGAIN, ANOTHER GUY THAT WON'T
LET HIS KID PLAY FOOTBALL.
>> Jordan: YEAH, YEAH.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
HE DOESN'T JUST LOOK LIKE THE
GUY WHO BROKE MOLLY RINGWALD'S
HEART AT THE BEGINNING OF EVERY
8 0SEE MOVIE, NO HE MAKES A
GREAT POINT.
I HEAR THINGS LIKE 48 PERCENT OF
AMERICANS WOULD ENCOURAGE A
CHILD WHO WANTED TO PLAY
FOOTBALL TO PLAY A DIFFERENT
SPORT DUE TO CONCERNS ABOUT
CONCUSSION.
AND I WONDER, WHERE THE HELL AM
I?
I HIT MY HEAD AND I'M NOW HALL
USE NATURING AN AMERICA WHERE
PEOPLE AREN'T EXCITED TO SEND
THEIR TOTS OFF TO BATTLE ON THE
GRID IRON?
WHO CARES.
PLAYERS RISK TURNING THEIR
BRAINS INTO DECONSTRUCTED
LASAGNA.
THEY DO IT FOR A GOOD CAUSE.
THEY GET SNEAKERS WITH THEIR
NAMES ON THEM!
BUT SOME FATHERS ARE JUST WUSSES
WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND A THING
ABOUT FOOTBALL.
WEAK, PENNY WASTES LIKE JUSTIN
TIMBERLAKE AND MIKE DIT KA.
-- TYPICAL, MID WESTERN COASTAL
ELITE.
IF THIS CONTINUES, WHAT IS NEXT.
KIDS PLAYING BASKETBALL WRAPPED
IN BUBBLE WRAP, DIVERS LAND NGHT
BALL PIT FROM DAVE & BUSTERS.
PEOPLE PLAYING SOCCER.
(LAUGHTER)
IT MAKES ME SICK.
THIS ISN'T EVEN MY COUNTRY ANY
MORE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST FOOTBALL, NO
WE MAY LOSE OUR GREAT AMERICAN
PASTTIME.
NO, NOT BASEBALL, BOWL BULL
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE.
WE COMBINE BOTH OF THESE
PASSIONS IN THE CLEVELAND
INDIANS.
HOWEVER, INSTEAD   I SAID IT
BEFORE, AMERICA IS CHANGING AND
I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> THE CLEVELAND INDIANS
ANNOUNCED THE REMOVAL OF THEIR
CONTROVERSIAL CHIEF WAHOO LOGO
FROM CAPS AND JERSEYS STARTING
IN 2019.
>> MANY GROUPS CONSIDER IT
RACIST AND OFFENSIVE.
>> I THINK THEY FINALLY CAVED.
1947 WE HAVE BEEN SEEING CHIEF
WAHOO AS A LOGO.
PART OF THE MOVIE MAJOR LEAGUE.
>> Jordan: YEAH, HE WAS.
CHIEF WAHOO WAS IN "MAJOR
LEAGUE" AND EVERYONE IN THAT
MOVIE IS STILL STANDING PROU
(LAUGHTER)
BUT THE SNOWFLAKES WANT TO
COMPLETELY DISREGARD THE TEAM'S
LEGACY.
SORRY LIBS THEY ARE THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS AND THEY
ALWAYS HAVE BEEN.
EXCEPT WHEN THEY WERE A MINOR
LEAGUE TEAM CALLED THE CLEAF
LAND LAKESHORES, AND A YEAR
LATER WHEN THEY WERE RENAMED THE
CLEVELAND BLUE BIRDSnd A
YEAR AFTER THAT THEY PRT
CLEVELAND BRONCOS.
AND THE NEXT YEAR THEY WERE
NAMED THE CLEEF LATH AND THEN
THE CLEVELAND MILLIONEE MAGUIRES
WHICH IS VERY, VERY CONFUSING.
BUT THEN THEY BECAME THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS.
SO HOW CAN WE POSSIBLY CHANGE
IT!
THIS IS ANOTHER CASE OF LIBS
FROTHING AT THE MOUTH TRYING TO
TAKE AWAY OUR HISTORY.
WHAT IS NEXT.
TAKING AWAY OUR CONFEDERATE
STATUES AND TODDLER SIGNIFICANT
ARS.
-- CIGARS, WHICH ARE-- WHILE
WE'RE ON THE SUBJECT, THEY ARE
TEMPORARILY STILL AVAILABLE IN
THE SHOPPOSITION.
THIS IS NOT THE AMERICA I KNOW.
BUT WE'RE NOT DONE.
PREPARE TO LOSE YOUR APPETITE.
BECAUSE CONCERN EL SANDERS IS
NOW GIRL-NAL SANDERS.
>> REBA McENTIRE NOW ROCKING
THE WHITE SUIT AND STRING TIE,
YES, THAT IS HER, MAKING HER THE
FIRST FEMALE TO TAKE OVER THE
ROLE.
A LOT OF COMMENTS, I WILL LEAVE
THEM RIGHT HERE.
>> NO PETE, NO.
DO NOT KEEP YOUR THOUGHTS
INSIDE.
YOU KNOW THAT GIVES YOU A TUMMY
ACHE.
LOOK, I'M NO SEXIST, MY DOCTOR
SAYS I'M HALF LADY DNA.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT A WOMAN JUST DOESN'T HAVE
THE STAMINA TO BE THE COLONEL.
WE NEED SOMEONE STRONG AND TOUGH
TO GUARD THE SECRET SPICE.
WHAND IS WITH THE PANTSUIT AND
SHORT COIFFED HAIR T IS LIKE
STOP IT, REBBA GO BACK TO THE
WOODS AND RELEASE YOUR EMAILS!
THIS CAN'T BE AMERICA, IT JUST
CAN'T.
IT'S-- GET ME OUT OF IT CHUCK,
GIVE ME A LAND I CAN RECOGNIZE,
DO GUNS STILL OUTNUMBER PEOPLE
HERE?
>> THEY DO.
>> Jordan: GOOD.
CAN YOU STILL GET A ROOT CANAL
IN A WAL-MART.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jordan: PERFECT.
DO MORE PEOPLE STILL LIVE IN
PRISON THAN IN WYOMING?
>> THEN WYOMING AND SOUTH DAKOTA
COMBINED.
>> Jordan: I LOVE IT.
WHOOO.
YEAH, THIS IS DEFINITELY STILL